let's give this a go put a big red box
matches or orange what success to tell
you an app and let's see how this
information can help us to unpack new
series whatever one times three one or
more times 3 that is this where K has a
value of what just one right because
that would be one and it data be three
you agree so therefore that first term
I'm just going to call this whole thing
as the series that first term of the
series I can rewrite at this aha outside
of one on K that's the first one but
it's 1 or k plus 2 that's second do you
see that this begins upon this is just
another way of rewriting this ok it
doesn't look like it's set up yet but
I'm hoping that some things will
collapse just like we had over here all
the dips of equals you tell me this time
still give your heart out the front
two minus one over four that doesn't
give this carrot numbers yes
okay again things that still look like
they're much an improvement but it's
always important to get that third term
this is because that's often where the
moji happen to happen let's have a look
at this last one here the trip there
it'll be again a half outside of one a
third is a bit right okay I'm not done
writing this light yet I'm going to have
to keep on going but I want you to
notice something that useful that is
happens do you notice something useful
that's happened if emerged I remember I
was hoping this would be the cancel
right do you see there's a third or a
half of it right there it's positive do
that have a look at the first term now
where do you know this is a minus a
third there there's a platter third
there's a ways of the these two things
are just going to collapse just like
these guys collapsed do you remember
that let me write one more term or you I
don't need to button copy sent to the
pattern and see what happens see what
emerges so if I go 1/2
what will the little bit
what take away a seat okay now what's
going to happen let's go to class
yeah this guy and this guy right so I'll
just label that this flag flag
okay so you can see if I keep going I
keep progressing this job can be done
this guy's going to be gone I've already
said this guy's gotta be right because
that's why I got rid of this one you can
see a whole bunch of terms are just
going to disappear okay let's keep going
let's just finish off this patent dot
dot now for reasons that I hope become
clear shortly writing least straight to
the last term I'm gonna write the second
month term as well so I'm going to go
one over K minus one
and they key is the very boss
just before we move on do you think
where I got this from to see how I
realized forward you add one to each of
the fact is so therefore you're
backwards I subtracted one for each of
exactly is that okay all right so what
are we going to get left right that's
that's the is whoops I'm busy for me
sorry that are only one of is separate
things ever it is merciful I want to buy
this
this pays it so this is going to be what
a hot outside
wata member what I do say K minus 1 and
K plus 1 that's 101 and a half outside
of what on K 1 K or soon yeah so I'm
trying to use it's alright so notice two
things number one everything is
reversible an hour half that to tell you
I don't have to write a half you know an
indeterminate over time I'm just going
to write it once all the way out the
front okay so now I don't need to make
those anymore how teachers are left
behind after all this carefully happens
since whatever one does it ever cancel
with you the answer is no because to
advance write the numbers just keep
getting bigger and so nothing will
overlap with this one over one so
absolutely all right that guy what
happens this guy
this caller he's been here be careful
right I'm just going to keep going
how about this does anything cancel with
this yeah just no because the numbers
keep getting bigger
I've already gone plus two everything
week three and five four six five and
seven I'm never going to come back so I
will have a half but I like the balance
after that this corner I've already
identified them cancel this 1/3 you've
already told them kids with that
I have every reason to cocoon is 1/5 or
cancel with this next term I haven't
written here everything is canceling
these are all vanishing away
right except now we get to descend with
the series right we get some business do
you notice I had two terms at the
beginning that were leather they didn't
pair with anyone I can think so there
are going to terms on the ends that are
also going to be left over that won't
carry things what are the terms that we
left over
maybe that I should have added the
multiple second master but nervous
what would we determine here I'll give
you clue it's cut to the heart
the list included [ __ ] what are the
parent passes good me never came by this
- and what a.k.a so have a look with
this
this guy is dying on cancer when this
one over here yeah this guy presumably
wouldn't be canceled by some earlier
turn that because just like this one
quarter was canceled by an early attempt
to two times just as we go so it should
also be done so therefore when you have
a little how many of the in terms they
got into left behind this on with kids
on this one should be canceled as well
right because it should have been cancer
by one two terms ago so this one should
be going to but what you get left with
is this guy and this guy why why is it
those two to get left behind the
sequence here the sequence is entered
this one third is counterpart is paired
up with something two terms in front so
you've got to go two times ahead to
cancel that guy out well see this guy
here he'd have to get canceled by this
guy in a part of series right and the
same way this one will have to be kids
without by that guy which is also not
positives
the make sense so the to the beginning
can they count heart with the two at the
end so what are they 1 over K + 1 + 1
over K +
okay so in problem solving which I said
to you with us it's sort of the main
thing that this whole course is about
back for a month my first week we're
trying to apply knowledge is unfamiliar
context and unrehearsed context we're at
life doing that that's it's like I would
like to patent that I think our formula
for this if I go okay but we're still
using somewhat the same skill right like
figure out the things that we've done so
far and it ratchets should you then try
to find a way that we could decompose
this so that we do dis carefully thing
that we've identified before it's just a
different kind of carefully so then D
after this you can simplify this down
remember you don't know what K is so
therefore you never have to put in a
value for you know about to substitute
it they just want you to simplify this I
just put it all into one fraction I
suppose we can say how much is going to
be 1 over 2 what will be the common
denominator here it's going to be a bit
gross but that's ok you're going to have
2 k plus 1 k plus 2 that right 2 k plus
1 k plus 2 so therefore if i write the
denominator here 2 k plus 1 k plus what
do you have to earn what do you have to
multiply say these to get up let's just
write them is 3 over 2 what do you have
to multiply this by to put on this
denominator
you just have to notify like campus on
campus if you've already got the to do
you notice that
so therefore this will be three months
old a plus one okay okay what we'll have
to multiply this by 2 and the k plus two
I've already got the k plus one so I'll
write 2 k plus 2 and in this last one
and then have to multiply by 2 k plus 1
there you go you can go ahead and
quickly verify if you have a look at
that is that going to be 3 or 2 and of
course it could be careful some tendency
canceled
what about this one is here is that
going to be 1 over k plus 1 you say of
course it is because the chisel kids
look and the caper statistically you can
go I've no idea what that will be where
you can simplify that out and there is
some solution okay so can we just step
back over time what do we do what was I
able to help you with the baby you
couldn't do yourself I wasn't sure what
kind of see this is going to be I still
don't know what kind of Jude is that
they made but I thought ok I'm going to
dad said I'm going to get each term
individually because if I could work out
something about one term then that will
apply to every single term so I got to
this why do I think it might be useful
to add subtract matches what maybe think
that refers much
Salem yeah very good if this is a series
you're adding up a bunch of things then
it ought to get some canceling
you should have addition or subtraction
right if you can write a product which
is gross in terms of a sum or difference
and something will happen here at least
we hope which is exactly what took place
I had to do some trade though like the
first thing that I tried did not give me
something that was immediately useful it
didn't give me something that I could
swap into the fuse
so I adjusted it I sort of tweaked it a
little bit until something that fit with
what was already in the question and
then I just had to pick that series and
I had to be willing to write out of
water terms just I could see the pattern
of okay